now under him we're a country of food  banks and bank bonuses a country of tax  cuts for millionaires while millions are  paying more isn't his biggest broken  promise of all that we're all in it  together Jeremy you can see the problem  that Labour have got they can't talk  about the deficit because it's coming  down they can't talk about employment  because it's going up they can't talk  about the economy because the IMF the  president of the United States all say  the British economy is performing well  so what are they left with when I tell  you mr. speaker they got an energy  policy to keep prices high they've got a  minimum wage policy that would cut the  minimum wage and they've got a hose tax  that has done the impossible and unite  the Honourable member for Hackney with  Peter Mandelson